uh now uh welcome david lovely to see
you again now what's the story are you
guys do you know each other are you
frenemies
what's the deal we're all old friends
old friends yeah we met a couple of
weeks ago yeah
um and it all came about with
uh my manager called me about six weeks
ago and said
uh something really exciting has
happened um
deadpool have been on the phone and they
want you to have a call with ryan
and uh and and do a skit with him and i
was like amazing this is amazing so
exciting they said he's going to call
you today or he's going to send you an
email today
about four weeks later i got an email
one week
four weeks later i got an email
and we had a conversation about what
exactly he wanted me to do and we did uh
this skit together which i think turned
out pretty good
because this is basic it's based on the
fact that you you made fun of david
david
yeah there's a there's a joke at david's
expense in deadpool 1
own it now own it i can hold on a second
it took 10 years to get the first movie
made right so when they greenlit
i celebrated a lot so i was on a huge
coke bender back then
i can't i can't remember a single thing
i said in 2016.
[Applause]
thank god people love you because um
no
very nice to have you here because you
live in new york now yes i do
and do they know who you are there
sort of like dude i mean do they know
you for the football or do they get the
vavavoom thing the the renault
actually it's kind of where the the you
know the the the nice thing in new york
is
whoever you are you can be yourself go
out
do your own stuff it's kind of cool so
you get the anonymity which must be nice
yeah it is
but here you know or even even in
barcelona you're in two countries that
are passionate
about football they love it you must
miss that you must miss
being able to sit at a bar and talk to
someone who you know has an opinion
no actually sometimes i don't want to
know the opinion
yeah and that is better uh no it's it's
true you know
i had the opportunity to play boss on a
great time and
as you guys know also at arsenal which
is great
but i enjoy uh not being the guy
uh in the front back page as you can see
here yeah
that's that's enjoyable sometimes to not
be recognized of course there is another
great footballer on the sofa
did you see keira knightley in bended
like beckham i actually did
[Applause]
i felt much better than he ever wrote
you did go to proper
football foot boot camp thing or
football oh yeah
yes football boot camp yeah did you have
to train i did have to train
i mean you know i know actually i played
i played it when i was at school
seriously i could have been a contender
i would have played for west ham um
i think it's still good right now i
think i can't
i have to say though there you all look
kicking the ball there
kira is a bossy girl because a little
bird tells me that you want to challenge
uh teary to a keepy up competition no no
i don't
no that's what i was told no no i don't
timmy's so competitive yeah i've got to
win
in the book you talk about how the kind
of rivalry between managers
so who was your biggest kind of rival
bet noir what would it be alex ferguson
he was my biggest rival yes for 10 years
and uh because they had
uh well there is shouting oh
yes me there yeah yeah you look like
you're you're just like zoning out
is he going i want my mars bars
where are the mars
i look like somebody who didn't get the
master
yeah you look like oh i forgot to get
mars
but was it really kind of properly
aggressive with him or was it just kind
of
no you're playing it wrong no no it was
right it's real you know
competition uh andrew could tell you
that
is real it's it's you or me because jose
mourinho i notice you don't mention them
in the book
no now this are you actually having
fisticuffs here
because that's a really pathetic looking
fight
you don't like you granted colin first
in bridgeton's diary
no you you tell your prayers you have
always to be in control of what you do
but
uh sometimes you don't manage to do it
do you remember what you were fighting
about
yeah yeah was it football no
we didn't talk a lot it was just a
physical there
and that's it was basically uh
me losing control oh did you start that
fight
i stopped that yeah
you can you can give me the yellow card
now pick a side or the red even
i just want to mention arsene wenger
because he was here um before christmas
and you were there at arsenal yeah for
that changing of the guard
were you one of those guys who were
really unhappy with all the
you know the new dietary requirements
all the discipline he
introduced i was devastated
you know you're talking about a black
man that needs seasoning on his food
you know so arsene wenger came in and
we're talking about
you know we'd probably have to eat eat
that and it's
like it is because like no salt no
anything all we can do is drink water
and eat food like the chicken literally
just boiled
and it just looks like just wrong you
know everything was just
you know it was just for fuel you
couldn't have tea
couldn't have tea couldn't have anything
i remember there was a time i used to
share a room with dennis burkham
and like dennis is the greatest player
i've ever played with and you know we
shared a room and was total opposites
chocolate cheese and
personalities and once we started doing
it
dennis done it to the right to the max
man you know if the boss said
you drink you think drink a quarter pint
of water that's what he would do
i would still drink i'd drink a pint of
water but the thing is
i remember i snuck in some tea bags and
um
so rock and roll yeah
i snuck in some tea bags and i remember
dennis he was just on
he's just on the bed because he was
sitting there watching to tell him he
said is that tea bags i said
yeah he said but the boss doesn't want
us to drink tea
he said yeah but he doesn't know what's
he gonna say yeah okay said yeah
okay so the whole team's doing but
you're not gonna do it so when we need
you most you're probably gonna let us
down because
you're letting us down honestly
so in the end i didn't have the tea and
then i didn't have the tea because at
the end of the day
what we went on to do with that team
because of him yeah
is because we all added to what he
wanted us to do he's an amazing man
he's an amazing man the thing about you
is extraordinary because obviously
soccer is huge in this country football
is massive in this country
but i think there's only been i think
three uh
soccer players ever have been on the
cover of american
vanity fair and you're one of them
you and ronaldo there because that i
mean that's a that's a big deal
yeah yeah
[Applause]
it is yeah you ain't foster paris with
you
[Applause]
because that i mean that sort of
recognition on a global scale
it was for the for the world cup 2010 in
south africa and
it was a special edition and i think
it was quite nice to be there yeah were
you both there at the same time for that
shoot
yes was that a bit awkward
that'd be strange like everybody was
trying to show them
[Applause]
isn't it great that even really fit
footballers have to do that
what was it like nice pants
welcome all welcome all hi heart love to
see you jessica thank you
now jessica's walmart champagne uh harry
you've gone with
i didn't know there was a menu
have you gone for a soft drink yes it's
diet coke oh lovely nice
and uh gary i don't know what you've
ordered but i love it it's uh
it's a large one it really is you could
probably get 30 glasses of wine in that
so this is the real fa cup that's the
one and how come i mean
you don't travel with it at all times no
no
i look like it but i don't cover it does
it always wear these ribbons
does it always have rib careful if you
break that
if you break it what's inside of that
anything do they put anything inside
argos
no actually you think you would
a security will come in and kill you put
it back down so tell me but you've won
it you actually wanted to yeah
yeah 91 with spurs so you know how
special it is to win it
it's very very special and it's back on
the bbc yes
and i've just come from cambridge
actually whiz there just now yeah that's
right yeah because this is live
who won
it gary a very big surprise cambridge
winning like that wasn't it
it was expected that manchester united
well it's a draw so there's a replay
well done very good
jessica chastain do you follow the
soccer that you with an outside chance
do you feel not really
no no and i know you guys call it
football here we do
i know that much well that's that's a
good start that is a good strategy yeah
do you know who david beckham is yes
because of his underwear ads
okay
i think you found the level of our crowd
an area football sport nothing anything
uh big fan dribble dribble dribble pass
man on
uh throw in no i never uh i never went
for it
so essentially gary i think the bad news
is of this group
i probably know more about football
and that's because i read about it
yesterday so uh
i'm gonna move this out of shot because
we can't really see you behind it
so i'll just put that down put that down
there safely
no back off no seriously we've been
abseiling into protective
now the fa cup for the uninitiated
hello what makes it such
a special thing well it's
certainly for a generate my generation
and perhaps a bit younger nowadays
there's lots of
you know football on tv there's games
all the time
but when we grew up when we grew up the
only game you'd ever really see was the
fa
cup final in particular um you get much
of the day that's been going forever but
you know
the actual live games the fa cup final
you wake up saturday morning graham
wouldn't you and watch all the build up
and
um and it's
every young lad that likes football and
there are some
there are some quite a few um he sort of
dreamt about playing the fa cup final
being part of it and i think
i think that's what it is it's a really
traditional event that was known right
throughout the world there are other
you know there are other circles but
also it does this thing of the because
what it does is this is the only thing i
do know about it is that it throws up
these weird things
where tiny clubs will suddenly be with a
major club
sort of david goliath the wonderful
thing about the competition is everyone
can enter
all the small teams and they it starts
in something like august
and then gradually they go through tiny
clubs
then you can meet a decent non-league
side then you can play against a
professional club
and if you get all the way through to
the third round you could
conceivably draw one of the the giant
teams the sort of the united's the
liverpool's etc etc and that match of
the day obviously it's going on right
the way through now because it's got
these fa cups specials believe i've just
have to explain
what the fa cup does
did you know you didn't know did you you
have no idea
you have no idea and you're you're
keeping your profile up with the sport
because you are also
still involved football now this is so
you're launching
at your own football club in miami
yes okay yeah good luck um
good luck thank you thank you um
well it's only taken five years to get
to this point but
uh you know we're very lucky to be in
the position we are at the moment you
know we've uh
we've now kind of uh found a site for
our stadium
because this is huge i mean it's not
like you're just giving them some
football jerseys i mean
no this is either this is bigger than i
thought it would ever be and you know if
you turn around to me when i was eight
years old and said
you know you'll have the career that
you've had and then you'll go on to be
an owner of a team you know that's any
kid's
dream but obviously any kids but yours
yeah
most kids dream um that love the game
um but obviously you know we've with
there's a lot to do you know we have to
we have to be in the league in two years
so we have to build the stadium
which won't be ready for when we come
into the league in 2020 but we have to
build
a whole organization in two years has
the team been fully cast
not yet not yet so i mean i've seen
these guys
yes we've got to know we've got a
picture of them they're here they are
look at them
real madrid you're all you're all
stomping aren't we on madrid
top tip you're only supposed to have one
ball yeah i know
i know guys with no arms and legs that
play football better than me
so that's just i'm dreadful at it you
were pretty good though you were you i
was
just pretty good yeah we play two ball
soccer yeah
and will victoria be involved in
designing the costumes
no no no no no
does that mean you move to miami uh no
i'll be spending a lot of time there but
obviously the kids are based here
with me and victoria obviously yeah um
and they go to school here so i'll be
spending a lot of time there but
uh yeah fun talking of kids you've
you've got the three boys who did all
play football
yeah uh but now they've basically all
dumped it and yeah
is so is harper the only one left uh she
is the only one left and she started
playing every sunday
um and i mean she loves it the boys
don't play anymore which is uh
it's heartbreaking uh
no you're out in the garden with the
goal i don't know
it's not really but uh they were playing
a bit at our show we're playing a bit
and they're great i mean they're
they're amazing yeah i mean they're
goofing around with the woods yeah
yeah they have a good they're they have
a talent but obviously none of them play
anymore so
uh it's down to harper um so she's uh
yeah i took her to
a training session the other day and
she's she's running around and
you know i'm quite a i wouldn't say an
aggressive dad on
on the side of the field because it's
probably the wrong thing to say
um but i'm very uh i just i get i'm very
enthusiastic
at that age is it a mixed team like it's
a great team it's a mixed team
okay and so harper's doing really well
she's kind of dribbling with the ball
and then this boy runs into her
and i was and i was like what had i was
looking around at the other parents
thinking how do i react do
did i like be a unicef ambassador
no it's okay they're fine or do i be
harper's daddy and be like really
um so i just let it go
but in your in your home country you
ended a civil war
through sport and through your i think
uh that must have been quite a goal
tell us what happened in the ivory coast
when so
you qualified for the world cup yeah we
qualified for the world cup and
the country was in uh was divided into
and
um there was a lot of tensions in the
country and
we decided the players decided to to
send a message to to the politicians and
we went down on our knees and
and ask them to put the guns down and
organize some elections and i think this
message was
was a good one because after that
we managed to to to organize elections
and no
no war and everybody was happy and
because in africa we are like
football is a religion so
when i have a chance to be in my
in my position and and send some
messages
i i do it and i'm lucky that people can
listen to me
this is unbelievable obviously we know
you were the greatest goal scorer ever
at arsenal
but this was you celebrating your 400th
career goal now
are you just a bit knackered
going to tell you how it's all started i
actually did the same celebration the
game before
and we were playing in houston i don't
know if you guys ever
been to houston yeah in the summer uh
it's hot and humid so i stopped by the
post because i was actually tired
can i just ask a question about that
photo taking what graeme's just said
are you knackered and what have you just
done to that goalkeeper
but also this guy this guy looks quite
tired as well
[Music]
actually it's exhausting playing in
america it's a slower game in america
it is actually that's the beginning of
the game in that game so
but the thing is this so this photograph
it kind of caught on and it's
been taken on as kind of internet meme
[Music]
internet
so we have we have some cute examples
this is this is the basic this is the
basic you supporting the ninja
pizza this next one i wish this had been
in the film
i love it looks like the people in the
audience really are looking at you
and then finally this is so zeitgeisty
and up to the minute
it's terry and miley
[Applause]
david did that hair bring you back yeah
i've definitely had that look you know
yeah is that why they cut you from
norwich
[Laughter]
the weird thing i guessed your man like
you're not rachel from friends
and yet whatever you do to your hair it
becomes a thing
yeah it does believe it or not yeah so
do you know some of you
have been really bad do you think ahead
do you kind of go home but i don't
no i don't there's certain ones that
i've just done just off the cuff
so there's no shame in some of them
before any of the hipsters were doing it
ashamed of any of them well you should
be ashamed of some of them
but before any of the hipsters were
doing it you had the top knot
there you go lovely that's always a
practical thing that's not bad yeah
it's fine it's fine this one okay what
was going on here
yeah that was that was maybe a bad
decision
it was a bad timing as well because i
was actually going to
south africa at the time with england um
and i ended up
meeting uh nelson mandela i know you did
and
and the pictures
so that's why that's why i regret that
there are other reasons but uh and then
the maddest one the most
on david beckham look i think is this
one
because that doesn't seem like you at
all big smiley face there
no well i i don't know why i had that
one
i don't i was asked to shave it off when
i first did it i was sat in the
changing room and i had a hat on at the
time because sir alex ferguson hadn't
seen it
um so obviously that was interesting
when i took my hat off and
we had an hour before the kickoff and he
said uh go and shave it off
which i said no at first and then i saw
his face change very quickly so
i went and shaved it off in the uh in
the
so how toilet alex ferguson wood
actually be sort of strict on that stuff
very
really very yeah what did he expect it
was just the you know it was a
reputation of the club
he wanted all the players to kind of be
professional and he felt that it wasn't
the right look and
i shaved it off we were playing at
wembley as well so he kind of had a
[Music]
point